I love bugs.
I think of them
as nature’s tiny engineers
because they come up with the most
extraordinary and incredible solutions
to life’s problems.
And I just love observing them
because they're so full
of surprises and curiosities.
During my career, I studied spiders
that use their webs as a slingshot
to capture prey
deep in the Amazon rainforest,
worms that tangle up with each other
and form knots to form
these shape-shifting blobs
to survive in harsh environments
such as sewers and caves,
and tiny aquatic beetles that bring
their own scuba gear when they dive,
on their butts.
But today, I'm going to tell you a story
about one of nature's
most extraordinary engineers
that pushes the limits
of fluid mechanics and bioengineering
and, arguably, solves
their number one problem --
how insects pee.
A few years ago,
my student, Elio Challita, and I
observed this tiny insect
having a private moment
in our own backyards in Atlanta,
and we couldn't believe our eyes.
This insect was peeing for hours,
and it was so quick
we could barely see it.
And we were blown away --
we had never seen anything like this.
We had never seen an insect pee.
So today, I'm going to tell you
how insects pee,
why they pee so much and in this way,
and finally, why you should care
about insect pee.
(Laughter)
So sit back and relax --
you're in for a treat.
(Laughter and applause)
(Laughs) So one of the first things
we had to discuss
is "Wait a second -- insects pee?"
And it turns out
that almost all insects pee,
in one form or another.
It's a closed system --
what goes in must come out.
But the protagonist of today's story,
Homalodisca vitripennis,
or a glassy-winged sharpshooter --
isn't it gorgeous?
You can see where it gets its name from,
it's got these transparent wings.
This insect specializes in feeding
on xylem fluid from plants.
It’s a sapsucker.
But I think of it as a plant's mosquito.
And just after a mosquito
sucks your blood,
it leaves behind a parting gift --
so do these sharpshooters
that spread bacteria into these plants,
and it causes devastating
and deadly diseases in plants,
killing them.
This is a huge problem in agriculture,
including here in California,
where it caused millions of dollars
in damage to vineyards.
And you can appreciate
what they lack in size,
they make up in numbers.
This is what millions of insects
feeding and peeing looks like.
If only this woman knew
where that water was coming from.
(Laughter)
Now, don't worry,
this insect's pee is just water.
And so for the first time,
I'm going to show you this behavior,
slowed down with our high-speed cameras,
and this is what we discovered.
We realized that this insect
forms a droplet of pee,
and then it flings them
at extreme accelerations,
of 40 g-forces.
That's 40 times faster
than the sprint of a cheetah.
These insects are really
packing a punch from their butts.
And we wanted to under-- (Laughs)
We wanted to take
a closer look at this flicker,
so we put this insect and took a look
under a microscope at its business end,
and this beautiful structure
has a scientific name:
it's called a butt flicker.
(Laughter)
And this is what we discovered.
We realized that this insect
had evolved springs and latches,
just like a catapult, so that it could
efficiently hurl its droplets of pee,
repeatedly, at these high accelerations.
Now, we wanted to measure the speed
at which this flicker was moving,
and the droplets,
so we measured the speed
of both the droplets and the flicker.
And this is where we made
a puzzling observation.
The speed of the droplets in the air
was faster than the flicker.
So if you take a ratio of that,
we were expecting it to be 100 percent,
but turns out that the speed
of the droplets
are about 150 to 200 [percent] faster
than the flicker itself.
This is why this is counterintuitive:
imagine a Yankees baseball player
throwing a ball at 100 miles an hour.
At some point during that throw,
their hands and fingers are moving
at 100 miles an hour.
Say an amateur ballplayer
throws a ball at 50 miles an hour,
and if you measure the speed of the ball
and it's 100 miles an hour in midair,
we’d be surprised -- where would
that extra speed come from, right?
This is exactly
what these insects are doing.
So to solve this puzzle,
we went back and looked at our videos.
And we’ll play this a couple of times --
see if you can figure this out.
Did you catch it?
Let me grab a frame.
We realized that
unlike a baseball that’s rigid ...
due to surface tension,
these tiny droplets are squishy,
and we had an “aha” moment.
We were wondering if this insect
is storing energy
due to the surface tension
just before launch.
And to test this, we did, naturally,
what any of us would do --
we converted our kitchen tables
into a lab to test this.
So now, we're going to place
droplets on a speaker,
to squish them at high speeds,
and this is what we discovered.
We realized that water that flows
in our faucets like a liquid,
at these tiny scales,
due to surface tension,
with the right timing,
can get a kick, store energy,
and if you time it just right,
you can launch these off
at extremely high speeds,
just like a child on a trampoline.
And to test this idea of timing,
we even built a catapult.
Our should I say a "cata-pee"?
(Laughter)
And it reinforced this idea:
too slow, the droplets don’t go off,
and then if you move
at the right speed, you've flung this.
So I've told you today
how these insects use
this catapulting structure
to store energy and surface tension
and throw these droplets
at record-breaking speeds
to be, really, number one ...
at number one.
(Laughs) But why have these insects
evolved this remarkable ability?
And there are two reasons for this.
Number one is they are
on a zero-calorie diet.
These tiny bugs are feeding
from the xylem fluid
that comes up through the roots,
through the soil,
and goes to the rest of the plant.
It's very, very poor in nutrients --
it's just water and some minerals.
This is unlike the phloem fluid,
which is rich in sugar,
coming through photosynthesis
at the leaves
and going through the rest of the plant.
This is akin to a human
purely sustaining themselves
on a diet of diet lemonade.
Very low energy source --
you'd have to constantly drink,
but you'd have to constantly pee as well.
This still doesn't explain
why these insects pee in droplets,
and not in jets, like you and I would,
if you were to take a bio break.
Let's take a look at cicadas.
These are the cousins
of these sharpshooters.
They're also xylem fluid feeders ...
and they pee in jets.
(Laughter)
I love this video.
This shows cicadas doing
two of their favorite things
when they come out of hibernation --
singing at the top of their lungs
and peeing in the wind.
(Laughter)
And the second reason why these insects
pee in droplets is size --
these things are tiny,
they're smaller than my pinky.
In fact, the surface tension
that enables them to store energy
in these droplets to launch
is actually an impediment,
because gravity doesn't matter,
and surface tension sticks
these droplets to their bodies.
So they actually have to flick
these droplets away --
it's actually very difficult
for these tiny bugs to pee.
And that's why I just love studying bugs.
This tiny engineer has figured out
how to survive on barely just water
through the xylem fluid.
And it’s figured out to do so,
it has to drink a lot,
and pee a lot.
In that sense, it's not so different
from other engineers I know
on a Friday night at a bar.
(Laughter)
But to do so,
it’s figured out it had to evolve
this catapulting structure
and fling these droplets at high speeds.
And that’s why I always tell my students
when we explore new bugs,
"It's not a bug, it's a feature."
(Laughter)
(Applause)
OK, so why should you care
about insect pee,
and what’s the practical
application of this work?
Maybe, maybe one day,
these ideas, these principles
could help us design
more efficient water-ejector systems
for our smartphones,
our watches and hearing aids.
But I have to be honest,
that's not really
why I've obsessed over insect pee
for the last four years.
I do this because when I share
my work with kids,
it ignites their curiosity.
When I talk about insect pee,
it makes their eyes light up.
They laugh, they run around
in their backyards,
looking at bugs and asking questions.
It reminds them and us that we can
discover marvelous in the mundane,
even in our own backyards.
We just have to look closely.
Thank you so much.
(Cheers and applause)
I've got to go pee.